les services de la rs et de la
démoustication sont en alerte
la dengue refait surface dont la caraïbe
avec un cas suspect chez nous dans la
période où l'on naît il est très
important de bien confirmer tous les cas
pour voir l'émergence d'un phénomène est
donc on a dans un premier temps beaucoup
travaillé sur avec les avec les
laboratoires pour bien mettre en place
toutes ces questions de diagnostic et de
confirmation c'est une procédure un
petit peu longue pour confirmer les cas
mais c'est absolument nécessaire au
moment où le boulot phénomène commença à
se mettre en place
ce colloque sera donc l'occasion de
faire un point sur une problématique qui
pourrait toucher l'ensemble de la zone
font avec des spécialistes et
scientifiques de la caraïbe pour
parvenir l'espère-t-il à jeter les bases
d'une coopération technique on aura les
gens de montserrat on aura des gens de
sainte lucie de saint kitts et nevis qui
vont venir dans un premier temps nous
présenter comment est ce qu ils font la
démoustication sur leur territoire
comment est-ce que laquelle effectif est
ce qu il dispose de quelques
insecticides
ils ont le droit de faire usage outre
l'état des lieux il sera également
question des prochains aux épidémies des
nouvelles stratégies ou nouveaux outils
de lutte ou encore de la communication à
adopter en cas de crise quand on dit
qu'on a cinq cas de zik a par exemple
sur un territoire c'est pas pareil que
quand on dit qu'on en a cinq mille on
attire beaucoup moins que la destination
est moins attrayant
donc c'est ce sont tous ces aspects de
communication de
comment faire le métier dans cet arc
caribéen mais également ailleurs parce
qu'on a des participants du calvaire des
participants de nouvelle calédonie de
cuba donc comment est ce qu'on s'en sort
comment est ce qu'on fait pour mieux
faire vis-à-vis de ces nouveaux engins
ce colloque débute mercredi avec une
trentaine de participants